Trascrizione: Federico Sangati
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Voi sapete chi è lui?
È un ornitorinco.
Un animale che vive in Australia.
Un animale strano,
e per questa ragione,
molto probabilmente,
ha sempre attirato la mia attenzione.
Vi saluta.
(Risate)
Guardatelo!
Ha il becco come quello di una papera.
Poi ha le zampe palmate,
esattamente come quelle di una papera.
Però non ne ha due, ne ha quattro.
Ha la pelliccia che è simile
a quella di un visone,
o - forse è più probabile -
come quella di una nutria,
ed ha la coda come quella di un castoro.
Ma la cosa straordinaria
è che è sia un mammifero,
ma depone le uova.
Depone le uova,
ma da bravo mammifero
allatta i cuccioli.
Che animale è?
È semi acquatico,
quindi vive sia nell'acqua
che sulla terra.
Ed è l'unico esemplare
della sua famiglia e del suo genere.
Non ha parenti, il che forse -
È un po' solo.
Poverino, descritto così
sembra un nerd, uno sfigato.
Invece,
se andiamo a vedere i testi miliari
della nostra educazione alla natura,
per esempio il Manuale
delle Giovani Marmotte,
lui è un animale
che ha delle qualità uniche:
ha il senso di elettrolocazione,
che pochi animali hanno,
cioè cattura le prede
individuandone l'energia.
È un nuotatore olimpionico
e nuota senza usare la vista,
ma usando gli altri sensi.
Poi può nuotare per ore
in acque gelide
e la sua temperatura corporea
non varia di un grado.
Quindi, per me, può essere tranquillamente
la controfigura di Keanu Reeves in Matrix,
un vero figo!
Eppure di lui non si sono dette
delle cose esaltanti.
La leggenda australiana narra
che nacque dall'incrocio
di un'anatra con il topo.
Il topo la rapì, si approfittò di lei,
e nacque lui.
Non proprio un buon inizio.
I primi coloni britannici che lo
individuarono e intercettarono,
lo uccisero - ovviamente -
lo scuoiarono,
portarono in patria la pelle intera
e lo fecero esaminare
dagli studiosi.
Gli studiosi britannici dissero
che un animale così
non poteva assolutamente esistere.
Era senza dubbio un falso,
confezionato ad arte
da un imbalsamatore asiatico.
In filosofia, è la metafora di tutto ciò
che complica le classificazioni.
Quindi: non è classificabile,
di conseguenza non è comprensibile,
di conseguenza non è un esempio.
Puntualmente, finisce
tra le specie vulnerabili,
che è la lista
che precede immediatamente la lista rossa
delle specie in via di estinzione.
A tutti gli effetti però,
ad oggi, non è ancora finito lì.
Io mi sono sempre sentita ornitorinco.
Non tanto per il mio fisico,
(Risate)
ho tutti i pezzi appartenenti
ad una stessa specie, sembra,
ma perché mi sono sempre sentita diversa
rispetto all'ambiente che mi circondava.
Vivevo a Selva del Montello,
un piccolissimo paesino
in provincia di Treviso,
ma con la mia testa
io ero a Seattle, negli Stati Uniti.
Perché da lì veniva la mia prozia, Oliva,
che dopo una vita vissuta a Seattle
rientrò in patria
proprio quando nacqui io.
Zia Oliva era la mia babysitter
e mi parlava in inglese.
In un paese, Selva del Montello,
dove, ancora oggi,
la lingua ufficiale è il dialetto.
Se tu parli italiano sei già strano.
Da piccola, poi, dicevo
di voler fare il falegname.
(Risate)
"Una femmina!?"
"Non puoi sognare di fare
l'infermiera, come tua mamma?"
"No, il falegname!"
Da sempre sono una gran chiacchierona,
in una famiglia di persone taciturne.
A casa mia, si possono passare ore
senza spiaccicare parola.
Io ero diversa.
Mi sentivo in un modo e capivo
di essere percepita in un altro.
Mi sentivo a posto, tutto sommato,
ma capivo di essere percepita strana.
E dietro di me, un coro
di pareri e frasi lapidarie.
Bambina socievole
in un'area geografica di orsi.
"Chiacchierona, lingua lunga!"
"Bambina con un'attitudine creativa."
E poi: "Voglio andare
a fare il liceo artistico."
"Di arte non si vive!"
Vado all'università; cosa scelgo?
Lingue orientali.
"Giapponese?!"
E poi decido di mandare i curricula
prima di finire gli studi
e mi assume un'azienda,
una multinazionale americana, subito.
"Chissà quando mai ti assumeranno..."
"Subito!"
"Senza una laurea
non vai da nessuna parte,
un buon lavoro non lo troverai mai!"
Dopo dieci anni di quel buon lavoro
nella multinazionale americana,
decido che è ora di cambiare qualcosa.
Capisco che non sono più
a posto con me stessa
e prendo la decisione di licenziarmi,
senza un piano B.
Quindi mi licenzio da un contratto
a tempo indeterminato,
senza un piano B.
"Ma sei pazza?"
"Non lo sai che fuori c'è la crisi?"
"Dove vivi tu?"
In quel periodo, che
è stato il periodo sabbatico,
che fa figo dire sabbatico,
(Risate)
sono tornata alla bambina falegname.
Ho avviato una piccola attività,
un laboratorio di compravendita
di mobili usati.
Non antichi: usati, vecchi.
Li compravo, li coloravo,
li restauravo, li rivendevo.
Indovinate.
"Figurati! Cosa pensi di fare?"
Vabbè, questi qua
in parte avevano ragione:
l'Everest della burocrazia italiana
non aiuta tantissimo
un piccolo laboratorio.
Vabbè, ho messo un attimo da parte
la "Civetta sul Comò", si chiamava così,
e mi riprogrammo, ritorno a fare
quello che ho fatto per dieci anni,
e dove comunque
avevo lasciato il mio cuore,
ma ci ritorno da libera professionista,
Libera. Professionista.
Vabbè, cosa pensate?
Il supporto?
"Chi ti ripiglia, dopo che hai fatto
il falegname nel mezzo?"
"Non ce la farai mai!"
Questa frase me la ricordo benissimo,
pronunciata da un consulente aziendale
che avevo interpellato.
"Che ne dici se... ?"
"Non ce la farai mai!"
Sono otto anni che faccio quel lavoro,
da libera professionista: felice!
(Applausi)
Eccomi qua!
Puntualmente, durante il percorso,
mi fermavo, mi guardavo dentro
e mi vedevo diversa.
Mi percepivo un essere diverso.
Ero la Ornitorianna.
(Risate)
Ho sempre fatto
quello che avevo in mente.
Sono sempre arrivata
dove volevo arrivare.
E vi assicuro che ho visto
tante magie accadere.
Da dove sono partita?
Ho sempre sognato tanto.
Io dico di me che potrei fare
la donatrice di sogni.
E mi sono sempre attrezzata
per realizzarli, quei sogni.
Lo sappiamo:
quando ci incamminiamo,
prendiamo il sogno e lo portiamo a terra,
e cerchiamo di realizzarlo,
incontriamo un sacco di ostacoli,
lo sappiamo tutti.
Il primo è quel coro lì.
Io però, a un certo punto, dopo tanto,
ho capito che il mio primo ostacolo
non erano i condizionamenti,
i giudizi, i pensieri, la voce degli altri.
E non era nemmeno la mia voce
interiore, condizionata da quelli.
Era un altro il mio problema:
un ostacolo molto grande.
Io avevo il bisogno assoluto
di far convivere in me
due anime molto diverse, opposte!
Quella creativa, artistica,
e quella molto razionale.
Due anime molto belle, molto forti,
con gli stessi diritti di esistere.
Avanzavo, tirata da una,
tirata dall'altra,
cercando di gratificare una
e cercando di gratificare quell'altra.
Quindi avanzavo
con il freno a mano tirato.
Ero un essere potenziale,
esplosivo, ma ostacolato.
Quelle contraddizioni interne
e quelle tensioni le sentiamo tutti.
E tutti, in qualche modo, e
per qualche cosa,
ci sentiamo diversi.
Però è una diversità
che è tutto sommato banale.
Il punto non è la diversità in sé,
è come ci stiamo dentro
a quella diversità.
Io ho sofferto tanto,
ma ho fatto lo stesso!
Tiro fuori il sogno dal cassetto?
Faccio!
Pianifico?
Cado, mi rialzo, aggiusto il tiro.
Faccio!
Mi tappo le orecchie,
perché io credo che l'ornitorinco
si tappi le orecchie, per non estinguersi.
Faccio!
Arrivo, al risultato?
E mentre arrivo al risultato,
sto già sempre facendo un'altra cosa.
Perché io ho capito
che non è il risultato che mi fa felice,
è il percorso che mi fa arrivare lì.
È nel fare che io sono felice,
ed è lì che voglio stare.
Per questa ragione,
io dico che per me
il fare è l'attivatore di felicità.
Faccio sempre,
anche quando mi ritrovo
nel buio, nel tunnel.
È quel famoso tunnel
dove vedi la lucina piccola, piccola,
poi si ingrandisce
e tu ti ritrovi asfaltato,
perché non era la lucina,
erano i fari del TIR.
Mi rialzo,
un po' appiattita.
E lì, mi dico questa frase:
"Marianna, guardati i piedi!
Questo è il momento
di guardarti i piedi ed andare avanti."
Questa frase è la frase che più
mi sono ripetuta nella mia vita.
Ed è una frase che è finita
nel Manuale di Ornitorianna.
Eccolo qua!
Adesso lo prendo e
vi voglio leggere delle cose.
Il Manuale di Ornitorianna
è una raccolta di frasi ad effetto,
come quella lì, di sprone, di stimolo,
regole, istruzioni, trucchi, escamotage,
ordini che mi do.
È la mia guida del fare.
Un po' come il Manuale
delle Giovani Marmotte, infatti.
Qui dentro, nella prima pagina,
c'è una frase, una dedica,
che io ho fatto a me stessa,
che è il mantra di Ornitorianna:
"Decido io chi sono nella vita,
non lascio decidere agli altri."
Che detta dai miei genitori, suona così:
"Assa star, tanto
co' ea pensada l'ha anca fatta"
Tradotto dal dialetto
di Selva del Montello:
"Lascia stare,
tanto non ha nemmeno finito il pensiero
che la sta già facendo."
È diviso in capitoli, molto lunghi.
E ho il piacere e la voglia di condividere
con voi due punti per capitolo.
I due punti che per me
sono stati più illuminanti, nel mio fare.
Il capitolo del "Do fiducia".
"Do fiducia a me stessa
e alle mie intuizioni.
Do fiducia ai miei amici,
ai miei alleati, ai miei cheerleader.
Quelli con i pon pon
che saltano, danzano
e tifano sempre per me,
perché mi vogliono bene."
Il capitolo del "Rispetto":
"Rispetto i miei valori e mi monitoro
con costanza, su questo.
Rispetto il tempo fisiologico
di cose e persone.
Io, di mio, sono una persona impaziente:
tutto, subito.
Non funziona, lo sappiamo."
Il capitolo del "Mi permetto".
"Mi permetto i momenti di sconforto,
tanto lo so, li supero.
Mi permetto la parte giocosa
in tutto quello che faccio.
Io mi devo divertire!"
Il capitolo del "Mi proteggo
da tutti gli accademici".
"In ogni cosa che fai,
c'è sempre qualcuno
con un titolo importante,
più importante del tuo,
che ti sa dire come devi fare
quello che stai facendo.
Probabilmente ha anche ragione.
Facciamo che facciamo lo stesso?
E poi, casomai, riaggiustiamo il tiro?
Mi proteggo, nella quotidianità,
dai deliri degli altri.
Questa è l'epoca del 'tutto subito'
di tutti, tranne per me.
Non ho capito: se non vale per me,
non vale neanche per gli altri."
Il capitolo dei "Non".
"Non cerco l'ancora dell'essere pronta,
non lo sarò mai.
Non cado nella trappola della vittima
carnefice del perfezionismo.
Non vado avanti,
se dopo aver sentito il cuore,
e analizzato con la testa,
la mia pancia dice: no!
Perché lei ha sempre ragione."
Il capitolo dell' "Accolgo".
"Accolgo l'errore,
tanto so che è funzionale
al processo evolutivo.
E accolgo la crisi,
perché è nel momento di crisi
che io riesco a conoscere bene me stessa,
a conoscermi meglio,
e riesco ad aggiustare il tiro del fare."
Con quel sistema lì
del "me lo metto in testa, faccio"
e con il manuale in mano,
recentemente ho scritto un libro.
Con un co-autore illustre,
perché sennò chi se lo filava
il libro di Marianna - comunque..
(Risate)
Non è stato semplice:
il primo ostacolo, il coro,
che poi in realtà era più
la mia voce interiore, [diceva]:
"Tu non sei una scrittrice". Vero!
Però volevo farlo lo stesso,
perché sapevo, dentro di me,
che avrebbe fatto del bene a qualcuno!
Poi c'era la voce reale dell'editore:
"Noi, libri così noi li facciamo."
Vabbè, vi ricordate i miei genitori?
"Assa star!"
Ok, libro pubblicato.
È stato un fare terribile:
cadute, tunnel infiniti, buio assoluto.
Vabbè, pubblicato,
primo risultato oggettivo.
E per rispondere all'editore,
dopo sole tre settimane
è andato in ristampa.
Ma il risultato vero,
per me, è stato un altro.
Io ho iniziato a ricevere
messaggi di sconosciuti.
Non i miei amici, che mi vogliono bene
e si sono prodigati a dirmi:
"Brava, quanto siamo fieri di te."
No, da sconosciuti.
"Mi scusi se la disturbo,
la volevo ringraziare per ...";
"Grazie per aver scritto queste cose.";
"Grazie per aver raccontato queste
e aver raccontato queste altre".
Quei grazie sono stati un'iniezione
di fiducia totale, e di felicità estrema.
Ma, soprattutto, mi hanno fatto capire
che il fare non è solo
l'attivatore di felicità per me stessa.
È l'attivatore di felicità
anche per gli altri, attraverso di me.
Ed è questa la cosa meravigliosa!
Io concludo dicendo questo:
L'ornitorinco è strano, sì!
Sentiamoci bene, nell'essere ornitorinco.
Vogliamoci bene,
accettiamo ogni pezzo di noi.
Conosciamoci, amiamoci
e diamoci veramente da fare
per essere chi vogliamo essere nella vita:
"Noi."
Lasciamo stare gli altri!
(Applausi)
Grazie.